la corruption intellectuelle et
financière du système et le manque de
préparation au type d'opération qui
était envisagée explique une grande
partie de la on va pas parler des routes
parce que l'armée est pas en déroute
mais en tout cas des très grandes
difficultés sur le plan militaire quelle
est confrontée la Russie aujourd'hui
quelle a tenté de compenser de manière
c'est très clair depuis depuis la
rentrée depuis le succès Ukrainiens de
l'été premièrement les grandes vagues de
bombardements stratégiques comme on dit
dans les dans le jargon militaire
c'est-à-dire qu'on essaye de casser la
volonté adverse notamment en s'attaquant
directement à la population soit aux
habitations soit aux infrastructures on
l'a vu une stratégie systématique depuis
le mois de novembre maintenant et par
ailleurs le recours à la moi j'aime pas
trop l'expression Shera canon en tout
cas on va on va dire le recours au
nombre pour dépasser pour dépasser les
insuffisances qualitatives et on et
dernier point on a vu quand même l'armée
russe très rapidement beaucoup plus
rapidement que ce que l'on pensait de
nombreux observateurs en recourir
j'allais dire aux fonds de tiroir quand
je dis au fond de tiroir c'est vraiment
le fond de cul du matériel militaire on
a ressorti très tôt des matériels des
années 1950 voilà donc voilà quelques
mots sur cette adaptation parce que
c'est vrai j'aime bien ce que disait
Anna cette adaptation on la retrouve le
bricolage j'hésite employer ce thème un
peu léger pour parler d'une stratégie
qui conduit à la destruction de milliers
de vies humaines mais il y a aussi des
tentatives de bricolage militaires pour
pallier les insuffisances que l'on sait
maintenant structurelles de cette armée
qui est je sais pas si c'est une armée
de de zombies mais en tout cas on sait
maintenant que sur le plan des matériels
conventionnels c'était une armée
totemkine comment l'a comme on l'a dit
également Anna Colin je sais que vous
vous diriez réagir
l'interview que nous avait donné Olivier
Todd dans laquelle il prétendait que
l'armée russe enfin que la Russie
faisait la guerre à l'économie notamment
l'économie d'hommes Emmanuel Todd pardon
Emmanuel je vous remercie de soulever le
sujet parce que c'est vrai que voilà on
a il y a un certain nombre de
contre-vérités qui peuvent être dites
sur sur cette guerre et l'une des une
des grossières qui était dans cette dans
cette interview d'Emmanuel Todd c'était
de dire que l'armée russe faisait cette
guerre à l'économie et notamment à
l'économie d'homme ce qui est
complètement à l'opposé en fait de la
stratégie de cette armée et je dirais
c'est à l'opposé aussi de la dynamique
qui a été celle de l'armée russe depuis
le début des réformes aux alentours de
2000 de 2008 c'est-à-dire qu'on a on a
on a eu quand même une je dirais une
dynamique dans l'armée russe de
professionnalisation à partir de 2008 de
réduction du de la durée de la
conscription de la réduction du du corps
officier et puis je dirais nous avons
observé nous avons observer ça dans sur
le terrain sur les premiers mois de la
guerre c'était essentiellement des
soldats sous contrat donc prétendument
professionnel on peut parler de leur
préparation réelle mais bon qui était
qui était lancé sur le terrain avec
peut-être un objectif effectivement
d'économie et d'efficacité mais depuis
le début la déclaration de mobilisation
partielle au mois de septembre de cette
année je pense que nous avons basculé
vers une logique ou un nouveau
effectivement on retrouve un certain
nombre de choses qu'on avait déjà en
Union soviétique le la vie humaine n'a
pas d'importance à partir du moment où
je dirais l'objectif justifie un très
grand sacrifice donc moi non plus je
n'utilise pas énormément le terme de
sherakano mais on constate aujourd'hui
que les mobilisés alors au début on
pensait que c'était un défaut de
d'organisation c'était sans doute aussi
un défaut d'organisation les mobiliser
n'étaient pas formés les mobiliser
n'était pas armés les ruisiers étaient
envoyés sur le terrain en basket et sans
une arme sans une autre arme que la
pelle pour pour construire des tranchées
mais on constate qu'aujourd'hui il
s'agit d'une véritable stratégie c'est à
dire que les personnes délibérément
lancé sur le terrain comme masse humaine
qui a vocation à être tué par l'ennemi
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir l'arrêter donc
là je dirais parler de d'une économie
d'homme et vraiment à l'opposé de ce qui
se passe sur le
tigre de papier l'armée russe c'est vrai
que moi ce qui me frappe pour avoir
écrit ce livre en 1994 donc c'est que
quand on retourne dans le passé de
l'armée russe notamment au XIXe siècle
et l'armée russe finalement se comporte
toujours un peu de la même manière
l'armée russe effectivement oui utilise
les hommes comme de la chair à canon et
c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui à
darkmouth et à soleda où ils ont envoyé
des
vagues tout à fait c'est à dire qu'il y
avait
10 ans on utilise de sa date d'être ça
le général hermolof ont à pratiquer
cette cette technique et aussi pendant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale la Première
Guerre mondiale on se souvient de de
toutes ces troupes qui étaient envoyés
en fait sur le front pour justement
pallier aussi d'autres d'autres
problèmes et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que au fond l'armée russe a
toujours des problèmes de logistique
depuis là aussi le 19e il y a toujours
eu des problèmes de logistique il y a
toujours une il y a souvent eu des
problèmes de de chaîne de commandement
est-ce qu'on a vu au début de la guerre
c'était bien le problème des chaînes de
commandement ou ils n'ont pas été
capables en fait de de organiser un une
enfin une organisation convaincante du
de ce que ce qui se passait sur le
terrain du renseignement et c'est ça qui
est apparu des sous-officiers qui alors
qui ont le sous-office l'encadrement
intermédiaire ça c'est un problème
structurel de l'armée russe et donc et
aussi bien sûr des problèmes de
logistique liés au fait que les les
charns n'avaient pas les pièces de
rechange qui avait pas de rations pour
les soldats ça c'est des problèmes que
c'est récurrent mais je vais poser la
question à Fabrice parce que vous avez
montrer que l'économie avait
résisté certaines manières
le pays est passé sur un mode d'économie
de guerre en fait depuis l'annexion des
quatre blastes et la déclaration de
mobilisation est-ce que l'appareil
militaro industriel russe est capable de
se refaire et de
d'amener sur le front
ukrainien d'ici quelques mois une armée
un petit peu régénérée ou pas votre avis
un premier point qui qui rejoint ce que
ce que vous avez tous les deux évoqué
sur le point structurel sur
l'encadrement de l'armée on a beaucoup
dit que les officiers
Ukrainiens étaient beaucoup plus faisait
preuve de beaucoup plus d'autonomie
d'initiative que que les Russes et ça me
rappelle des commentaires comme
faisaient des officiers français quand
j'étais à Moscou donc ça date d'il y a
une douzaine d'années maintenant qui
avait des échanges avec des officiers
russes à l'époque puisque les relations
étaient plus que cordiales et qui disait
mais même dans en temps de paix on
s'aperçoit qu'ils aucune marge de
manœuvre aucune marge d'initiative c'est
un une chaîne de commandement
extrêmement rigide et ils sont
incapables de la moindre faiblesse c'est
une faiblesse alors du point de vue
matériel je dirais sur le long terme à
mesure que les sanctions commencent à
apprendre et faire ça va être de plus en
plus compliqué de trouver des certaines
pièces de remplacement même si analysait
qu'il y avait eu des stocks des stocks
importants notamment grâce au covid même
s'il y a des stratégies de contournement
assez éprouvées via des pays comme le
Kazakhstan via l'Inde avec lequel le
commerce était énormément développé ces
derniers mois pour certaines pièces
vraiment techniques qui permettent de
réparer un char un avion ça va devenir
je pense de plus en plus compliqué donc
il faut parler pour l'armée c'est la
désinstitutionnalisation actuellement
des opérations militaires parce que
aujourd'hui il est troupes
aujourd'hui ce qui est absolument
frappant c'est que les forces qui ont eu
le plus de succès
vous sentez qu'on puisse parler de
succès vraiment important c'est pas le
cas c'est les milices Wagner c'est la
ministre
mais en tout cas ce qui est frappant de
manière générale c'est qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez des armées quasiment privées
qui se sont cons qui sont constitués et
qui se battent de manière autonome sur
ce front et critique en permanence comme
le fameux
danger aussi pour le régime et je
voudrais qu'on en vient justement à la
résilience du régime est-ce que sur quoi
repose-t-elle est-ce que c'est la
fidélité de des gens qui entourent
Poutine est-ce que c'est la propagande
est-ce que c'est la répression selon
vous Anna Colin les BDF je dirais que
pendant les 20 dernières années le
régime
à se reposer sur une promesse de
stabilité et de prospérité en tout cas
de perspective de prospérité pour
certains ou d'amélioration du niveau de
vie pour d'autres il s'est reposé
également sur l'idée qu'il ne fallait
pas s'engager dans la politique qu'il
n'y avait rien à ça il y avait aucun
idéal susceptibles d'être suffisamment
grand pour qu'on sacrifie sa vie pour
cela on invité les citoyens je dirais
d'investir dans leur vie privée de faire
leurs petites affaires de faire leurs
petites affaires en manipulant en
opérant dans un environnement
extrêmement corruptif mais quand on
savait y faire et qu'on montrait une
loyauté à l'égard de l'État on avait des
rétributions à différents niveaux et
donc je dirais que cette promesse de
stabilité de prospérité et ce qui a
marché ce qui est complètement frappant
aujourd'hui c'est le renversement je
dirais de demande que le pouvoir adresse
à la population là on demandait à la
population de se démobiliser aujourd'hui
on lui demande de se mobiliser alors de
se mobiliser militairement donc de
sacrifier leur vie pour un certain
nombre pour un certain nombre de
personnes mais se mobiliser aussi
politiquement d'être voilà d'avoir une
posture forte alors je dirais que la
mobilisation peut passer par la
coercition mais s'il n'y a pas un degré
d'acceptation à un moment donné bien
évidemment ça ne passe pas et là
une fois de plus je dirais que oui on
peut on peut év ce que ça entraîne pour
les pour les Russes ordinaires mais il
me paraît plus intéressant de parler par
exemple de d'élite civil et pas
forcément d'ailleurs d'élite militaires
délits civils pas forcément proche du
Kremlin pas les oligarques dont on parle
le plus souvent mais je dirais d'élite
de niveau intermédiaire et de bas niveau
au niveau local le maire les le chef du
commissariat militaire le directeur de
l'école tous et toutes ces personnalités
là en fait on pèse je dirais dans la
dans la vie politique et doivent mettre
en oeuvre les politiques de l'État et
notamment celle de la mobilisation le
chef d'entreprise locale et je dirais
tous ces gens là font des calculs coût
avantages et pour l'instant le seul
moyen pour eux de qui leur semble je
dirais accessible pour préserver ce
minimum de stabilité de prospérité de
prévisibilité qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
réussi à construire et bien c'est
d'aller avec le pouvoir aussi parce que
je pense qu'on n'a pas l'alternative
n'est pas visible si on s'oppose au
pouvoir quand on est au niveau des
élites intermédiaires qu'est-ce qui
arrive mais je dirais les calculs c'est
calculs sont faits en permanence ils ne
sont pas fait une fois pour toutes et je
dirais les techniques les techniques de
grève du zèle qu'on voit le chef
d'entreprise qui va envoyer tout son
personnel en télétravail pour que
personne ne soit mobilisé oui ils
préserve son business certes mais il
manque aussi je dirais il est dans une
posture qui peut être qualifié de non
patriotique donc on est on est on est à
un moment je dirais non pas de
basculement mais je dirais que si à un
moment donné l'équilibre change il n'est
pas impossible que toutes ces élites là
changent également de posture et
d'allégeance une fois de plus non pas
pour des questions de valeur non pas
pour des questions d'opposition à la
guerre mais pour préserver ce qui compte
pour eux et ce qui a compté pour eux
depuis la chute de l'Union soviétique
leur position de pouvoir leurs
ressources et l'avenir de leurs enfants
pour une autre est-ce que vous êtes
frappé par le phénomène de de maintien
vous avez décrit tout à l'heure les
lacunes de la de l'armée russe dans la
guerre mais pour autant tous les chefs
qui entourent Poutine sont restés les
mêmes certains ont changé de position ça
veut dire que quoi en temps de guerre il
n'a pas un réservoir de loyer de loyauté
telle que il puisse se permettre de
tester de nouveau conseiller de nouveau
chef d'état-major d'abord en premier
point sur l'aspect prévisibilité moi je
une hypothèse que je voudrais tester
peut-être avec vous il y a peut-être un
scénario de très grande prévisibilité
dans la durée c'est celui de la guerre
permanente à partir du moment où vous
êtes en guerre pour très longtemps où la
guerre s'installe dans votre quotidien
il y a plus que cela comme horizon c'est
quelque part peut-être aussi un élément
de prévisibilité dans dans le système
deuxième point avant de répondre à votre
question mais on y reviendra peut-être
tout à l'heure dans la dans la
discussion ce dont parle à nain c'est
c'est aussi le signe que ça n'est pas un
état totalitaire on peut discuter c'est
une discussion légitime avec son savoir
si la Russie est devenue un État
fasciste je suis en train de régime
fasciste parce que de réponse définitive
on va en parler mais pour l'instant je
voudrais au moins dire c'est que pour
moi en tant que politique comme
comparatiste je ce n'est pas un régime
totalitaire et un des éléments qui
permettent de le dire c'est justement
cette passivité cette débrouillardise
cette aptitude a préserver quand même
son destin individuel plutôt que que le
collectif alors maintenant sur sur la
question de savoir si pardon c'était la
loyauté
est entourée des mêmes gens qu'au début
de la guerre même s'ils ont failli vous
savez très bien qu'il y a on l'a dit on
l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est un système
dans le c'est un système mafieux dans
tous les sens du terme financier en
termes de relations humaines tout le
monde se tient par la barbichette si
j'ose dire et ils sont tous prisonniers
les uns des autres et le système les
emprisonnent et ils sont eux-mêmes ils
ont eux-mêmes créé ce système donc vous
pouvez avoir un jeu de taquin entre
Guerra simov shoegool l'un ou l'autre
etc mais le fait de on peut avoir
sûrement trouver quelques têtes mais
d'une certaine il écoute pas il
réarrange le dispositif c'est une
manière de faire la même chose sans
introduire des gens dont il n'aurait pas
forcément à la confiance absolue et qui
viendrait tout d'un coup prendre la tête
d'une opération ou voir la tête de
l'état major ou
du ministère de la Défense donc je pense
que ce qu'il fait aujourd'hui c'est à
peu près sa seule marge de manœuvre
parce que c'est probablement trop risqué
pour lui de faire venir quelqu'un tester
de nouvelles exactement tout simplement
de ville sur quoi repose la la le régime
est-ce que ça fragilité ça force c'est
quoi oui justement je pense que il
repose d'abord sur Poutine c'est à dire
que effectivement on est arrivé un point
de concentration du pouvoir en Russie ou
me semble-t-il Poutine finalement dans
une certaine mesure
et tout
l'autocratie en fait à atteint un stade
assez paroxystique qui a fait que en
fait tout l'ensemble de ce régime et
notamment toutes ces structures tous ces
hommes se clan à la fois partiellement
mafieux du KGB etc reposer sur lui et
c'est vrai que les il y a évidemment des
combats de dogue sous le tapis la
formule de Churchill qui ont continué
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir et qui ont
toujours existé en autocratie mais mais
il est non parce que justement c'est ce
que raconte tous les gens qui ont étudié
l'autocratie et un
comment dire un penseur du 19e siècle
que je cite dans mon papier qui
s'appelle léozan Leduc qui raconte en
fait ce que ce qu'est l'autocratie russe
et qui montre en fait que quand un
autocrate et par définition un état
fragile un pouvoir fragile parce que il
dépend de gens qui sont assujettis mais
qui sont tellement qui n'ont aucune
autonomie et qui au fond font ce qu'il
dit mais on peut aussi le tromper et
donc en fait c'est ça le paradoxe de
l'autocratie c'est que c'est un pouvoir
c'est une puissance impuissante et je
pense que à partir du moment où il va y
avoir des des failles dans le système le
système peut aussi se défaire mais mais
ce dessert assez vite je pense avec des
des périodes de troubles des luttes
peut-être même un élément ça peut venir
de ces différentes factions qui
pourraient de ces hommes qui vont
revenir peut-être du terrain
ukrainien
ultra armé en colère il peut y avoir
toutes sortes de scénarios c'est
vraiment une boîte noire aujourd'hui la
Russie il me semble il me semble mais il
faut pas oublier pour je comprends en
fait que Anna veuille montrer qui est
assez stratégies d'évitement qu'il y a
ces stratégies privées etc mais ce qui
pas seulement frappant c'est quand même
la capacité que les Russes ont quand
même une tradition de fonctionner sous
l'économie de mobilisation et une
société de mobilisation parle par l'État
jadis totalitaire et aujourd'hui très
autoritaire et avec une sorte de je
dirais de rechute néo totalitaire dans
la violence et tout ça et donc on voit
quand même cette société qui se met en
ordre de bataille pour la grande
bataille et aujourd'hui c'est quand même
extraordinaire de voir que le pouvoir
que vous avez dans les écoles les
enfants qui se mettent au garde à vous
qui récitent des champs en disant que
les nazis doivent être vaincus et
détruits etc et que ça et ça si vous
voulez ça se répand alors ça veut pas
dire que les gens n'en pensent pas moins
et que dans leur cuisine ils sont pas
d'accord et qui qui vont faire ce qu'ils
peuvent pour essayer de négocier en fait
des stratégies de vêtements mais il faut
pas oublier non plus cette capacité et
alors la question c'est à partir du
moment où lui
vaffaiblir qu'est-ce qui va surgir ça
c'est là la question c'est à dire est-ce
que ça sera un des clans il va y avoir
cette bataille de clan il y a plusieurs
clans qui sont certains parlent du clan
des Sanguinaires pour parler du clan de
priscogyne cadirov j'ai vu un papier en
fait qui est sorti dans destrucide
d'autres du clan des copains
c'est-à-dire justement le clan de cette
Chine de covalthuk de tous ces gens en
fait qui qui ont grandi ce sont ces gens
là qui vont le débrancher Poutine qui
vont se battre les uns avec les autres
parce que comment vous voyez les choses
évoluées vous je suis d'accord quand
l'or dit que tout peut s'effondrer d'un
coup et très vite sauf qu'en attendant
qu'on a quand on connaît la Russie de
l'intérieur on se dit ce régime qui est
très dur peut s'effondrer d'un coup il
peut s'effondrer d'un coup mais en même
temps en attendant comme disait Bruno
ils se tiennent tous par la barbichette
et avec aussi de la peur je pense des
gens même du premier cercle ont peur ils
se disent si je suis le premier à bouger
le petit doigt pour m'écarter de la
ligne qu'est-ce qui va m'arriver et il y
a un cas intéressant à
sur lequel réfléchir c'est une Mitry
metzvdef qui a été le président par
intérim 2008 et 2012 à l'époque alors
est-ce qu'on était complètement naïfs
un très bon comédien oui il y a quand
même beaucoup de d'experts qui avaient
l'impression qu'il y avait un petit
début de Tournon un peu libéral il était
certain responsable politique y compris
au plus haut niveau en France bien sûr
nous avions un président et un premier
ministre qui de bonne foi estimait et
misait effectivement sur sur
de ministres assez moderne qui avait
l'envie de moderniser le pays de
diversifier l'économie et puis quand on
voit ce qu'il est devenu on se dit parce
que au fond de lui-même vraiment il
pense toutes les les horreurs qu'il dit
et aboyer beaucoup plus fort que les
autres dans dans
ce que vous en pensez l'extrémité
incroyable je pense qu'il de toute façon
qui fait partie du système et que il
devra périr avec le système il n'y a pas
d'échappatoire mais je trouve que ça
pose des questions
parce que je pense que c'est important
de regarder les personnalités on voit
des personnalités émerger aujourd'hui
dans cette guerre donc c'est normal
qu'elles attirent notre attention
certaines d'ailleurs veulent attirer les
lumières sur eux et il faut faire fausse
méfier du trop de lumière qu'on met sur
certains personnages mais c'est
intéressant aussi pour moi en tant que
politique de regarder les structures et
de regarder les institutions et en fait
la dynamique que l'on a connu dans la
dans la Russie poutinienne c'est une
progressive des institutionnalisations
dans les années 1990 les institutions
veulent dire quelque chose la Cour
constitutionnelle est une cour
constitutionnelle les parties sont des
partis qui représentent des clans de
personnes mais néanmoins il y a une
sorte de voilà de pluralité qui
s'exprime et d'opposition entre des
acteurs qui s'expriment etc un président
est un président un premier ministre un
premier ministre aujourd'hui et ça a été
fait progressivement petit à petit à
chaque pas en fait nous avions
l'impression de perdre quelque chose
mais que bon au fond tout n'était pas
perdu toute ainsi toutes les
institutions ont été complètement vidées
de leur sens c'est un système qui tient
uniquement par des allégeances
personnelles et donc une allégeance
personnelle au sommet
justement ça le rend extrêmement fragile
dans la mesure où par exemple vous voyez
le jour où Poutine disparaît et c'est ce
jour-là arrivera bien évidemment
le les institutions la structure ne
seront pas suffisantes pour penser la
succession ou pour assurer la succession
c'est à dire que l'on sait que vous
voyez dans la mesure la Constitution
prévoit ce qui se passe en cas de en cas
de décès ou d'incapacité du du Président
c'est le premier ministre qui prend
l'intérim et puis ensuite des élections
sont organisées sauf que dans le Carrus
institution ne veut pas dire grand-chose
Premier ministre ne veut pas dire
grand-chose Constitution ne veut pas
dire grand chose ça a été ça a été vidé
de son sens donc ça le fragilise et
cette fragilité on la voit également sur
le front avec l'émergence notamment des
armées privées la présence des armées
privées alors je pense mais je pense
aussi à la manière dont kaderov qui est
un acteur officiellement public
gouverneur de région qui voilà qui se
soumet normalement au centre et qui agit
en autonomie
qui pourrait le dévorer je ne pense pas
je ne pense pas mais en revanche je
pense que ce sont des symptômes
extrêmement puissants en fait de la
perte des d'un certain nombre de
capacités de contrôle de l'État et
notamment par exemple et bien du
contrôle de l'exercice de la violence
quand on pense effectivement à la
manière dont un prix gaugine aujourd'hui
à la capacité de contourner le système
le système pénitentiaire en recrutant
des des détenus pour pour les envoyer
sur le front la manière dont il peut les
il a le pouvoir de les libérer les
exécuter mais aussi de s'imposer sur le
terrain réfléchissons à la réaction des
des de l'armée russe et des militarus
qui est sans doute la seule institution
qui continue à fonctionner et avoir une
réalité institutionnelle je pense que ça
fragilise ça fragilise l'état de
l'intérieur
[Musique]